we will go to our next call here from
the five one seven area code caller
what's your name and where you calling
from hey what's up man my name is al
mommy first off I just wanted to say I
like to show dude and I was gonna I was
going to ask a pretty troll question but
now I'm gonna be serious or say okay yo
um uh cool sure yet role not all your
your call well now you're kind of making
it hard non-skid bottom in light of this
whole Trump thing like him leaking
classified info dude how long do you
think it's going to take her in to get
impeachment I'm disgraced right yeah I
don't know I mean it's oh so number one
out of curiosity what is your
understanding of what it means to imbue
Donald Trump um well I know that getting
impeach doesn't necessarily mean getting
out of office I think it's just about
like court proceedings yeah and then
that could lead to his removal from
office okay good good because there's a
lot of people who are emailing me who
think that impeachment means you kick
Trump out and clearly you do know the
truth about that and that's not the case
I think that it's it's certainly
possible that inside of six months we
would see impeachment proceedings start
that's a different question than what
specifically would the impeachment
proceeding to be over because you were
saying Pat earlier this week that you
don't actually know that there has yet
bit that there's a lot of smoke but you
don't know that there's actually
something that is impeachable so far
well the thing is you have to get
Republicans on board and they're not
going to turn against them just based on
any circumstantial evidence really that
I turn against them on anything aside
from the Russia collusion story so I
think that either the FBI investigation
or one of the congressional
investigations has to prove something
first what do you think I mean if you
had to handicap this thing what's your
sense um well I don't know to be honest
I just want him out bro for real but
he's such an idiot like he can't he
can't speak above a fifth-grade level
and he's willing to give away info like
that just because he wants
like you know macho up and prove that
you got some over done you know yeah
yeah I said it before like how insecure
do you have to be to want to brag about
the Intel you get as president of the
United States like hey you're president
of the United States that's not
something really to be bragging about
well thanks so much for the call really
really appreciate it to hear from you
again and thanks for I guess thanks for
not trolling today you know he almost
trolled us and decided not to
hey guys file this though if you're
going to troll you just have to do it
you can't make the announcement for you
know it's like I'm going to tell a joke
you can't say that for I agree with you